hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week today we're talking about cmmc
control
ia.l2-3.5.6 disable identifiers after a
defined period of inactivity
[Music]
all right let's talk about it so control
uh cmmc control
ia.l2-3.5.6 disable identifiers after a
defined period of inactivity uh well of
course the first real question is what
on Earth is an identifier uh that is
indeed a great question uh identifiers
are typically the key field related to a
user which uniquely identifies them and
typically doesn't change a great example
of an identifier might be a username
although it doesn't have to be it could
be an account identifier but a lot of
times people most commonly associate it
with a username uh something that
uniquely identifies that user account
probably would have been easier if they
had just used the term account instead
of identifier making everybody run to
Google and try to take a wild swinging
guess at what this thing is but again
this is a standard it has to be designed
to the best of its ability to fit the
widest variety of systems the language
used is you know a challenge for sure
now why is this so important right let's
really why is it important well the more
accounts that have access to things the
larger the number of accounts the larger
the number of Potential Threat factors
through those accounts exist when
accounts sit idle and don't have their
passwords changed or users accessing
them to report odd activity happening
with those accounts over time the risk
continues to grow that someone will be
able to hack in and gain inappropriate
or unauthorized access so this control
stops that by saying hey look uh make a
defined period of time and disable those
accounts make sure that they don't just
sort of openly have access forever
and ever and ever
so let's dive into what the assessors
are looking for on this one to get a
better understanding so they're looking
for two things one is determining if a
period of inactivity after which an
identifier is disabled is actually
defined uh yeah some somewhere we have
to Define how this works so I'll give
you a great example identifiers are
disabled after a period of 365 days of
inactivity per the it operations policy
yes some written policy may be a great
way to do this user account status is
reviewed at a minimum annually right so
we're going to explain how we're
reviewing this it service tickets are
created upon review to task disabling
identifiers after this period of
activity now again this is sort of a
more small to medium company kind of way
to handle things right so we're
essentially using some manual
interaction with the system to prove
that we're able to disable that
inactivity or those inactive accounts
after they've passed that 365 days again
we're gonna have to really get this
documented well otherwise it won't it
won't really pass
second assessment Point determine if
identifiers are disabled after the
defined period of activity so again the
assessor is going to be looking for can
I prove that they're disabled we're
going to say this is implemented review
Baseline configuration review and
compare to current system configuration
so again in our Baseline configuration
we're probably going to be able to see
those accounts and how long they've been
active or when the last login occurred
and again compared to current system
configuration to make sure that any
group policies or anything like that
they're in place to help with this are
actually working so again this one's a
little bit more technically complex to
figure out how to do this but again lots
of ways to do it again manual
intervention sometimes is needed to
solve for some of these controls there
is a human element so hey if you're
trying to get compliant with dfars nist
SP 10171 or cmmc on your own and you're
looking for help our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links that will make your
life easy okay seriously check out the
description below amazing stuff it'll be
really helpful to you it doesn't cost a
thing there there you can find more
information about how we can help
self-schedule time at your convenience
with one of our compliance experts
through any form on a website or learn
more about our completely done for you
services that can have you on your way
to being compliant in just two to three
days and hey if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance service roll it out it's a
great way to stay prepared for that
upcoming cmmc certification that
everybody's going to have to go through
all right until the next compliance tip
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to learn
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
thank you
anyway